[Music]
what happened oops all boys boys welcome
back to the break room everybody it's
the daily nerd show that brings you the
news you need to know live from New
rockstars actual break room here in Los
Angeles California
Manitoba no well yeah we're not even in
we're Los Angeles oh that's true uh um
yeah we're technically in the County of
Los Angeles but uh coming up today on
the show uh there's a movie coming out I
I feel like people have mentioning it
before the rock stars The Flash well
that is kind of delay it again there's
movie today coming out uh that all three
of us have yet to see but we will be
seeing today uh we're very excited about
that black panther wakanda forever what
could end up being the biggest movie of
the year or at least one of the three
biggest Marvel movies of the year at the
minimum um so we're super excited we're
going to talk about that this will be
kind of the our final pre wakanda
forever episode of the break room we
were just saying in the chat we do want
to warn people uh a don't do spoilers in
the chat if you've already seen the
movie or you've talked to somebody who
has but also it will be hard to prevent
some spoilers if there's some Bad actors
there so there's gonna be plenty of
people putting in fake spoilers too I
see Ben Smart saying killmonger is in it
I mean I haven't seen the movie but that
could be a fake we don't know we don't
know how about fake spoilers only I hear
I I did hear a spoiler that in this
movie they finally explained how 616
affects Uncle Ben dies oh good thank God
oh maybe maybe we'll get to hear a
little bit from that scene uh later in
the show maybe but also in this episode
of the break room
um the Magic Begins for Agatha Harkness
coming of chaos uh John Wick refuses to
die oh my glasses aren't for that we've
been asking and we're gonna make our
final predictions about wakanda forever
before we see it and again half the
staff of new rockstars has seen wakanda
forever but not this half so uh we're
coming in honest yeah uh our predictions
are just as naive as anybody else is in
that they're not informed by seeing the
movie yeah
um joining me here today on this uh uh
three man Deus we've got Brandon Barrick
that's right and I want to remind you
folks as you go see this film this
evening and anytime you see a film at
the conclusion of the movie if you've
purchased snacks or drinks take your
garbage to the garbage can okay thank
you don't make the poor saps poor sap
the people who work at movie theaters
clean up after you they got enough to do
you can take yourself to the garbage can
it's not that hard that's right I don't
know how that got inside you're gonna
pass it on your way out yeah you're
gonna pass it on your way out the
garbage I used to be one of those people
worst thing that ever happened to me was
I walked in on a couple having sex
during a movie their baby was next to
them that's fast and that baby turn
around town and that baby was taught me
back oh my God yeah as big of a devil
he went away
to Dime in the back of the theater we
got John costumes all right I got a
flashlight at all times
break it up break it up and I'm Zach
Huddleston uh we thank you all for
joining us today thank you to everybody
blowing up the chat a couple people
already super chatting us we appreciate
you we'll try to get to uh all the super
chats by the end of the show and in fact
you know what if we get 200 bucks today
we'll do 15 extra minutes of the show
just reading super chats we gotta get to
the movie answering questions I know we
can't do 20 minutes because then we'll
be late and we don't miss any previews
but uh we will do 15 extra minutes if we
hit 200 bucks but uh watch that way of
the Water trailer six more times do we
get a whale trailer for this one oh in
front of we'll do a trail we'll do
trailer predictions we're gonna do
trailer predictions at the end of what
kind of forever predictions
um and real quick you might have noticed
the fourth guest today the the oh wow so
fine folks at Xbox sent us a free
wakanda forever uh salute series X
console look at that that is a gorgeous
piece of work also these cool
controllers with the we were saying when
you sit them by each other it makes the
wakandan salute like the top of the
hands and now I don't think this does
anything with the Xbox but they also
send us some very cool uh kamoyo beads
and these things are heavy
um these will not get through airport
security no word yet on if these are
made of real vibranium but uh thank you
to our friends we're gonna play the hell
out of this we were just talking about
we're going to download some games yeah
and uh we're gonna get we're gonna play
some overcooked and get into fist fights
hell yeah uh so shout out thank you to
the great Folks at Xbox uh and uh of
course what kind of forever
um which we're excited about can people
buy this no oh exclusive no uh now if
they make us an offer we might be
tempted no just kidding we'll die for
this just kidding
Let's uh let's do some headlines
uh okay great well as as previously
mentioned Agatha Kevin of chaos yes
previously House of Harkness currently
Covenant of chaos
um apparently word on the street is
start shooting like next week right yeah
um and so what do we know about this
obviously it's following Catherine Hans
Agatha Harkness character from One
Division and uh the only other confirmed
cast member from One Division that has
been confirmed to be in the show is
um Emma coffee Emma Caulfield who played
Dottie the kind of blonde Stepford Wife
type character in that series but other
than that like here's the cast this show
has a wild uh confirmed cast Aubry Plaza
uh Maria dizzia who you probably
recognize from Orange is the New Black
she's been in a bunch of movies Joe
Locke ollie on sashir zameda former SNL
cast member Eric Andre crazy
truly crazy crazy
um and then there are some rumored cast
members okay now we don't know any of
these rumors some of these might be true
some could be false all of them could be
false we don't know Amy polar Sasha
Baron Cohen who's again been rumored to
be Mephisto possibly in the MCU
Catherine O'Hara crazy and Hannah
Waddington the tall lady from
umasso uh which again even the Possible
cast members that's a show I would watch
is that is that the best cast comedy you
know like if it's a comedy what if it's
a serious straight drama well it's
interesting I mean one division kind of
had it both ways right it was a sitcom
format though the the show was largely a
drama right right like could this be
going for a similar tone it would be
interesting yeah if if in Agatha's
header she's in prison she's still stuck
in like sitcom mode and maybe her magic
is still present and starts to manifest
itself out the same way you know wanted
it I don't know there was a lot of
rumors too it was going to be a little
bit of a flashback type show that's my
big question right does it take place
right after
we get all the Scarlet Witch stuff is it
gonna be an origin story is it gonna I
was hoping it'd be about how she got the
dark hold in the first place that's a
big argument I had around the office a
lot like yeah because in one division we
see her at the stake her parent her mom
and the sisters are sucking their magic
out and they're like you dabbled in some
dark magic and everyone I think you
believed that like she has the dark hole
at that point and then hangs on to it
for like yeah I thought maybe those
witches had the dark hold and then you
know I don't know if Multiverse Madness
kind of came in and said maybe yeah yeah
because why would these witches have the
dark code
maybe there's another powerful magic
book that's what I think she was just
doing some Darkness the um uh shadowhold
the uh uh dust cold the um more more
dark books please more gramours please
uh but I do think two that what they
established in uh Multiverse event is
the dark hold in the 616 was a copy
right so maybe there was other copies
right right because they had to destroy
the the temple yeah that was that was
the real dark hole maybe we even see
that she did have the dark code at one
point and lost it and that's how it kind
of came into uh uh Dude where's my
darkhold dude where's my darkhold all
the people in the chat saying who who's
directing there's a few people directing
but actually for his at least confirmed
to be directing one episode of this show
she's the head writer for the from Wanda
division in for the show yeah they've
been back shackman to do okay and didn't
they say Jackman's a busy boy yeah
she's she's doing the white Vision show
too right yes I believe so oh I mean
could that be a basically a de facto
third season of One Division this is the
de facto second season that is the de
facto third season what's interesting
because this the one division was comedy
drama right this seems like it's gonna
be it's I think it's supposed to be Nine
episodes seems like it's gonna be mostly
comedy I don't think you could make a
half hour sitcom with white Vision I
mean I don't know world's driest
[Laughter]
If part of that show is white Vision
realizing I need Agatha and why Vision
helps her get out you know because we
were talking about a comic run the West
Coast Avengers run where vision goes to
meet King the Conqueror to sort of say
hey I need you to like fill in the
blanks I don't have all of my memory
what if you know she could totally go to
yeah yeah she can go to Agatha for that
real quick just before we move on from
uh Covenant of chaos so none of these
names are established MCU characters
there's no uh Kamala Khan showing up
there's is now even even the hood or
whatever no actors that we know are
playing other characters in the MCU who
do you think most likely if if somebody
does even a Paul Bettany or an Elizabeth
Olsen who do you think might show up in
this that that's already been
established yeah I like a Wong I like my
chances
you can't go wrong with Wong you know
it'd be great if we see Jacob battle on
who's uh budgeting a wizard and these
magic magic wheels he just sort of
sneaks into some sort of Magic Clip we
haven't seen any spum CMC new series
crossover bold prediction John Posner
um okay moving on uh so we still don't
have a director for Avengers six right
someone direct this movie yeah so Kevin
feige was asked about this as he uh on
presumably doing some black panther
wakanda forever press uh and he was
asked specifically if what kind of
forever director Ryan coogler might
direct the film a lot of rumors about
that coogler recently was like I I
haven't thought about it I don't know
what I'm doing I need some time yeah
yeah but this movie's not for several
years it's 2026 now 20 26 so he could he
could take a long vacation and come back
and start working on that but uh when
asked about it Kevin feige gave a very
diplomatic kind answer you know well I
would want Ryan to do anything at any
time because he's a singular talent and
a great person to spend years with but
no in all honesty there have been no
conversations we've not spoken to him
about Secret Wars now he didn't say
we've not spoken to anybody about Secret
Wars of course they're they're having
time I mean there's definitely uh a list
somewhere yes and there's probably some
names already crossed off that list yep
yeah well and also hey if you're working
on your short film that incorporates a
lot of CGI and uh yeah Marvel IP
honestly get it made now and maybe you
can get in front of Kevin feige and get
that direction they would never do this
and I love the like uh behind the scenes
like assembles they do but like an even
deeper one where it's like
pre-pre-production assembled that's what
I would love to see because usually
that's like foggy on the phone sweating
a little bit that usually doesn't come
out to like a Hollywood Reporter writes
a book about it 10 years later yeah when
they talk about like all the people that
said no and like the negotiations and
somebody wanted too much money and like
remind me of the per so we we have
shackman doing Fantastic Four we have uh
Dustin Daniel [ __ ] doing uh Kang
Dynasty you think they're just gonna
lift from who who is the person who
directed all those episodes of Loki like
that feels like it could be a really
good fit for this already has we talked
yesterday about how they're kind of
using the farm league yeah they're using
the Disney plus series to kind of
develop some talent but they're also
going in both directions they're also
having some directors of the films like
Dustin Daniel [ __ ] or Ryan coogler
produce some of the series but not
direct them per se was it Kate Heron who
ran yeah that's right did she direct a
lot of the all the I know she her thing
was like she presented this idea she she
gave it to them she made the show but
did not want to do season two because
she was like that was the story I had
and I'm kind of out right I think she
did direct all of them okay and Walton
wrote them it'd be interesting to bring
her back in on something and now that
we've seen that concept art where it had
a probably a very different ending which
she originally pitched because it
sounded like her thing was like I just
want to tell the story and be done with
it and they're like no this is great
we're gonna make a season two and she's
like I don't want to choose and we've
talked a lot about how even separate
from other MCU films these big Avengers
team up movies are a different Beast
right they feel a little bit more like
TV there's a reason the Russo brothers
who came from TV had so much success
directing those team up Marvel movies
because it's like you know a and b and c
and d and e plots right and they all
need to intersect and you're managing so
many moving pieces it's a lot like a
television absolutely and I think that's
why a lot of people want Ryan coogler to
do this movie right he is he's one of
the most emotional sort of directors in
the MCU people are comparing this movie
me to the the last Black Panther movie
and and how much emotion is in this film
and also like this is we were talking
about this in the office earlier this
movie doesn't really have a protagonist
that we know of maybe it's shuri maybe
it's Neymar we don't know but like this
is the most Ensemble movie that we're
getting from a singular character title
film so he would be a great choice to
like juggle all for sure and we know he
knows how to play horrible game totally
right he's made multiple projects there
they want to do more with him in the
future so like it's a specific thing
like to succeed within that system is
not something that all even really good
directors have that skill set right
um moving on to other Avengers uh topics
simulu come on the show simu please the
door's open uh no you're not a coward
yeah did you see by the way did you see
like he went to a an event and his
outfit was just not wearing a shirt I
know we don't have that asset I think it
was a Halloween party or like it was
like oh it was Rihanna's uh fashion line
thing okay um but his outfit was he wore
like Silk pants and just no shirt and
homeboy if you could do it you'd do it
he could do it
um come on the show see me show us those
abs or not or you wear shirts we don't
wouldn't that be the best the best
version of simu coming on the show is he
just shirtless walks past the camera and
then exits what if he's just like he's
just like jumping rope and doing burpees
in the background while we try to do a
show but anyways he was asked about
appearing in Kang Dynasty uh you're
talking to comicbook.com and he shared
how excited he was for Destin Daniel
[ __ ] who directed him in the shung chi
film uh and that guy is now going to
direct
um King Dynasty that's his next uh
Marvel work yeah that guy's busy with
Marvel right he's got that he's got
wonder man he's got this 10 Rings series
uh who knows if he's directing any
episodes in those two series and we
don't know
supposedly Wonder Man and ten rings are
far down the road but but they might be
hitting around the time that this hits
he's producing those but anyways um and
he was asked about Destin Daniel [ __ ]
directing that and he said I'm so
excited to get to work for him again
oh is that Simo letting it slip that
he's in Dynasty I think he's a little
thirsty and and oh oh
yeah that's the first time Graphics has
actually happened well one of the
foundational thirsty things yeah yeah it
was just for people to change their
memory much more of uh he's always on
the Mount Rushmore I mean his career is
built on effective thirstiness
um but uh he was kind of asked to
clarify and he said uh he's like is he
gonna be in King Dynasty and he's like I
would think so I would hope so don't
take my word for it he has to know he
also said in that interview that he
heard about Destin doing King Dynasty
before like a little bit before it was
announced so you got to think if his boy
is texting him like Hey I'm going to do
this movie he's gonna be in it yeah yeah
and he's clearly like a part of a lot of
Marvel's future plans the shangshi
character right we're gonna find out
what how these rings are connected to
the Bengal how and any other jewelry
that exists out there uh there's a
bigger story there and I bet it does I
bet the Rings have a big part of Kang
Dynasty interesting like so yeah I mean
remember they set up the McGuffin of
these rings are calling out to something
we don't know where they came from what
they're made of what they're calling out
I don't know what they're called they
don't have to know when they wrote it
but uh I I think the Rings and the
Bangor are gonna all play a big part
yeah but do you think leading up to
Secret Wars one of the things we're
theorizing with Secret Wars was okay
maybe we don't want another you know
okay Infinity war was all about Thanos
collecting Stones like do you really
want to do another like we got to
collect these artifacts movie but like
it would be cool if if excuse me the
Avengers got together John I'm excited
uh The Avengers got together and we're
like the only way we can defeat this
person is if we kind of grab all these
different things across the Multiverse
or whatever and then and then Ken gets
them and he just throws them like Luke
throws the lightsaber yeah it doesn't
matter didn't matter uh yeah you need
some kind of McGuffin or some kind of
you know mother box or or something like
that for a lot of these films I like
that it could be those those Rings
um and in non-mcu news we got a John
Wick Four trailer someone oh got to kill
John Wick it's gonna be Brandon do we
have that are we able to play the
trailer we don't have the truck okay but
anyways
we're excited about that that's coming
out first half of next year I believe
John Wick no one did enough research
2023 release uh the fourth movie really
the fifth movie in that franchise if you
count Hotel Artemis they're not
connected I thought the same thing Zach
those movie Hotel Artemis in the John
Wick franchise are not connected at all
no but I thought it's where he goes no
he goes to the Hotel Continental or the
Continental Hotel uh yes much like most
of America who watched that movie on an
airplane probably thought they were
connected they they seemed very similar
very similar like remember the that uh
Amazon showed them which was also
written in like red curly fonts looks
like they're similar to us yes it was
like the marketing team was like we
wouldn't hate it if you thought okay we
need a new rockstars video somebody call
up Eric Voss or uh Whitney van laningham
or somebody we need to break down of how
Hotel Artemis is not yeah I didn't proof
that it's not or or maybe we've all been
fed alive and maybe it's a low-key
connection okay I don't know how we
ended up talking about something that's
not in the John Wick franchise while
while talking about the John Wick
trailer but uh check that out if you
haven't seen it we might we might be
covering some John Wick stuff in the
future here on on new rockstars let us
know if if you're into that franchise
and you want us to cover that more
um okay in a moment we're going to get
to our final predictions for black
panther wakanda forever but first we
want to shout out uh the second season
of the hit show DC's Batman the audio
Adventures out now on HBO Max you
subscribe to HBO Max for House of the
Dragon I do White Lotus Euphoria
succession succession it's not coming up
for a while
whenever The Last of Us The Last of Us
in January well they are they have a
show right now DC's uh Batman the audio
Adventures the second season's out the
two seasons already
um this one has an awesome cast Rosario
Dawson and Jeffrey Wright Bobby Moynihan
um all portraying our Chris Parnell
yes Keenan Thompson what a cast
um all portraying uh The Dark Knight and
his Rogues Gallery up to no good uh the
audio Adventure is a little dark a
little comedy and it's a feast for your
ears uh features again all the the best
characters from the Rogues Gallery we've
got a Catwoman we've got a joker a
scarecrow Harley Quinn everybody in
there mix and imagine uh fighting our
Cape crusader tune in for a tale of life
and death in Gotham City whole season
one is available already to stream and
season two is out now on HBO Max stream
DC's Batman the audio Adventures season
two now on HBO now I should have
downloaded the HBO Max app played this
in my car on the way it's been raining
in Los Angeles lately it just like you
know white knuckling it down the 405. we
can't watch
you can't watch House of the Dragon in
your car no okay but DC's Batman the
audio Adventures perfect for the car
perfect for the car uh and we should
shut out today you might see him in the
chat right now recently suspended Tommy
bechtels hanging out in the chat it is
his birthday today
funerals uh bills Bill's Mafia forever
uh happy birthday we hope your
suspension and soon Tommy we can't wait
to have you back uh for legal reasons uh
but yeah send them a happy birthday and
thank you for sending him your super
chats uh we we do appreciate them and be
sure to like And subscribe to the video
if you haven't already uh uh there was
one Super Chat Matthew nonya said did
Thanos snap and now there's only boys on
the BR uh basically basically no I
snapped I said I said we can't have any
more what kind of forever viewers on the
show yeah we didn't predicted we didn't
get all the things we see the movie get
out of here Jessica was splitting things
left right and Center oh my God it's
true um so let's talk about our main
discussion today uh before we get to our
black panther wakanda forever final
predictions uh Chris Evans has been
doing a little possible possible thirsty
that's being actually doesn't have to
play the game he doesn't need it he
doesn't need to I don't know if you know
this my wife brings this up every day
and I we haven't talked about it on the
show yet he was named sexiest man alive
oh Chris Evans People magazine sexiest
man keep him alive
someone keep him alive uh in this
article
goes on to do the super annoying thing
where he talks about how ugly he is yeah
he was like I'm getting older anytime I
like eat a sandwich it shows and I was
like dude I I I I I hear you Chris every
time I put down my fourth sandwich for
the day I feel a little bloated I
thought it'd be for doing three three
hot dog lunch
the key the key Chris you're not feeling
bad about yourself or eating a sandwich
never get ripped yeah yeah yeah yeah
always stay I've been working on that my
whole country
uh but he was asked about uh playing
Captain America and all that and he did
say uh quote it's been one of the
greatest choices of my life to kind of
dive in and prepare for these movies
they're challenging but the beauty is
the movies are great and you get out
what you put in it's been a wonderful
very symbiotic relationship so I've been
thrilled to do it when the movies end
you're very happy to have a break but
very quickly you miss it I miss it now
but I'm very grateful very happy to have
been a part of them please save me from
The Gray Man
I thought
he did kill him but maybe he just beat
him with an image of his life can we can
we get a pole Ryan Gosling definitely
lives did great man die the dude the
dude man wait does the dude from
Bridgerton die okay I can't remember I
watched all that movie it was felt like
five and a half hours long but yeah all
I remember is anadarmus running with
over 100 pounds of gear and I was like
that that can't be right for her she had
so many Bazookas she weighs less than
100 pounds I mean you saw uh Emily Blunt
to it and lift every piece
was shredded for Edge of Tomorrow right
I repeat for her a Sony Pictures film uh
great move if you haven't seen that one
please watch that uh get the steel box
4K uh but back to Chris Evans folks he
misses play in Captain America how could
you not miss it you know he was one he
was one of the early guard where when
you signed on you signed on for seven
movies they don't really do that anymore
well and and you know like how much of
the success of those early phases of
Marvel was built on the fact that like
RDJ was into it yes Chris Evans was into
it Hemsworth into it right like these
weren't just guys taking a paycheck they
really enjoyed this they owned it right
they love doing the Press together they
seem to really like you know they were
not mercenary about it get in some of
these huge Hollywood blockbuster movies
which you know you know I think they had
to right if you are locked in for seven
movies that's at least 20 years and
credit to Marvel for obviously treating
them in a way and I felt heard and they
felt like they had some agency and some
ownership over these properties and then
they all you know went off to make
generational wealth off of these off of
these films and so you know buying in is
the way to get through a 20-year
commitment we all you know we all can't
wait to get out of high school but as
soon as you're gone you're like man I
wish I was back in high school I was the
king I was the king uh we are getting
confirmation from the champion he did
time no he's okay come on uh I saw just
Jennifer Henry killed them someone said
Lloyd died in the body roll that clip I
need I need to see a pulse stop the poll
the poll was yes set 57 nah 42 okay
I love that there were only 92 votes
implying that not a ton of people saw
that movie he's Counting if you're in
line stay in line okay but but if Chris
Evans decides like man I gotta get back
in that MCU I'm sick of being beat up on
other movies like I want to be the King
again I want that best the best trailer
on the lot how could we bring him back
right uh is it is it more likely to have
because they haven't confirmed cap dead
yet that's they're still swinging on the
moon uh he's on the moon he's an old man
like in theory this old man could go
back into the time zone and come back
the younger version of himself right I
don't really know how it works Scott
Lang basically dates yourself yeah yeah
uh so I don't know but is it more likely
to have the 616 cap come back or like a
variant of cap much like we've talked
about with like Tony Stark RDJ Tony
Stark right yeah is it more likely to
have like Chris Evans comeback as
Captain America or from the 616 or is it
more likely to have him as like a
variant do you think
variants still played by Chrisette yes
yes he's just from a different timeline
because I I will say that like I don't
think either Chris Evans or we the
viewing public wants to see a full film
of old man cap no no we don't want him
as old no it's not fine it won't be fun
because like also like so does he John
actually does want to see that yeah
unless it's like go ahead go ahead
unless it's like the Indiana Jones five
or it's going to be a clip show right
why do we pull that where he has
memories about what he did yeah that
could be fun but I don't know I I saw
the Irishman I don't need to see long uh
and this would be the opposite of the
Irish but they would be aging him up but
you want Benjamin buttons is what you
want yeah that's right uh no because
only because Chris Evans is still a
young viral man I don't and and like
that is our image of Captain America is
kind of that I don't know because I I
feel like that very oh you make your
point okay
you know here's the thing Chris Evans
has always said I'm only going to return
like I loved what we did with the
character The Arc is complete I'm only
going to return if it's really
meaningful I think it'd be a disservice
to Sam Wilson if you bring back a young
yes yes a young Steve Rogers right
um and so I think you come you bring him
back he's old he's maybe in a mentorship
capacity or he's there to like do some
kind of final like he needs a final
send-off you know we we got that on the
bench but they're like a Batman Beyond
Bruce Wayne where he's training yeah
maybe that or like or like God damn it
we need a little bit of extra backup and
they like the shield flies in one last
time and then and then an electric
scooter comes in yeah
well or or like it makes me think of
that that series with uh Bruce Willis
and Helen Mirren and John Malkovich read
right where it's like also you know you
have this super powered guy out there
yeah there's gonna be like some Hydro
sleeper cells are like we can't let
Steve Rogers just exist he's too you
know the potential there is is too scary
so like I I've talked to myself
but I also agree that like we could see
Old Man Steve Rogers he I don't think
he'll have the shield and the outfit and
whatever because I think it does make
sense he needs to pass that torch and
even a variant variant just feels like a
cheat right you know what I mean like
that's a trick they're gonna do that
trick and they only get to do it they're
gonna do it in figure Awards they kind
of teased it in Multiverse of Madness
right where we're in the trailer we're
like oh my God we're getting keptic and
it was like no these are just some
variants we're gonna kill off yeah for
fun you can't go to that well too much
if you're gonna make a full movie with a
character and you're gonna say that they
are a variant you know you you can only
do that once Loki's kind of getting away
with it only because we like Loki so
much he died died and it almost fits
that character the variance and time
travel and things like that I wonder
like you know we're all watching and are
obsessed with Andor right now like Rogue
one is an interesting potential what if
we get a one-off right like in between
the times we saw Steve Rogers in films
he was doing other stuff I would love
like a Howling Commandos movie The
Adventures of the Howling Commandos and
camp and Bucky I mean you get that black
widow movie though I know they didn't
quite execute I think a lot of people
are looking at Carl Lumley and [ __ ]
the Winter Soldier and saying like ooh I
would have loved to have seen Bucky
versus uh Elijah right yeah back in
there yeah I thought it was going to be
in the show it would have been great it
would have been great uh obviously you
can't do that Captain America he's nice
the whole time but you know something
like that maybe makes sense
he'll never know he'll never know
uh well that's a crazy dream dude so uh
if we don't bring back cap right because
the MCU the the infinity Saga right was
kind of built on some foundational
characters holding the movies together
as like a through line right uh is that
something you think they're going to
continue doing for they've kind of done
it we have like Nick Fury who refuses to
die he's kind of like a through line but
they brought him over from the previous
franchise Wong Doctor Strange any of
those even like Wanda has become a big
Nexus point in the MCU right do you
think they're going to still keep
establishing those type of characters or
are is the is the the gallery getting so
large that it's like no there's not
going to be these characters that are
like the main well we know we know
there's the Thunderbolts we keep
speculating that there will be a Young
Avengers right will there be just a
grown folks Avengers right like and what
we need is you need that battle of New
York scene where they're all back to
back to back right to confirm like oh
these are the six or whatever right like
because there's so many oh it would
Kamala Khan be in there is keep it shut
up no Hawkeye's still alive
is he an Avenger that's a really you
bring up a good point because I've been
thinking about this uh this from the
perspective of end game where it's like
you need characters in secret Wars to
sacrifice themselves for the greater
good and we need to feel emotionally
connected to those characters uh like
they did for you know Tony and Steve
um but maybe you're right maybe it is
more of the Avengers model where it's
like oh we just actually get to see
these characters be badass together for
the first time and we'll have their sort
of sacrificial moments yes in in six
seven years I mean that's more more
likely I think that we we kind of do
need and I think that they probably
wanted like t'challa to be one of those
characters who you know is so grounded
in the emotion of this this universe and
wanted him to probably carry that moving
forward
yeah of it right yeah well and that was
a big thing with cap that worked so well
uh is that he passes the shield on right
uh and that's something that you know
t'challa and bike Panther that's that's
literally a mantle you pass on to the
next person uh yeah what what are the
next characters gonna be able to do that
well I don't want to discredit uh
Anthony Mackey who who has the shield
you know passed to him but Don Cheadle
was just doing an interview about armor
Wars and he was sort of like we never
really got to see the backstory for my
character and I'm excited to explore
that more so so even though you know Sam
Wilson does have the shield he's another
character that we don't we don't have a
ton of even though we had a can't get a
bench well we had a TV show I just don't
feel like what's in his history he can't
get a bank loan yeah well he saved the
universe can't get a benchmark I don't
know government employee for a long time
he's out there shrimping
um big shrimping big shrimp and
catch and see
I mean I know that she's maybe dead or
still evil or whatever but like
I think she's the person that audience
members will resonate with the most and
I mean
well I I'll just say too it's only been
what three years since end game right
that was 2019. yeah
um right like to bring him back soon
wouldn't be as nice I'd say like oh but
looking forward 2026 maybe Beyond phase
seven or something like that like a
cameo a flashback or whatever imagine
how like awesome that would be right
like he would it's kind of like what
we're getting with Logan yeah in uh
Deadpool 3 right like we all had our
closure on that character it was like a
nice send-off he didn't come right back
he's getting a long enough break that
like you know we've had time to process
it and miss it I kind of want that too I
I would love to see Chris Evans well GSU
Eagle one one seven just sitting at
Super Chat saying what if we get a what
if Episode Two what ifs in the same
sense of something of cap in the other
timeline he lived out with Peggy I mean
that's a great show right yeah
I mean there's definitely going to be
more of Captain Carter in I think they
said she's sort of the central character
of what yeah maybe like Doctor Strange
was I love it by the way that's just
supposed to come out the beginning of
2023 23. where's our what if training
we haven't heard anything about that now
animation can sometimes get delayed it's
hard they've got to send stuff to Korea
or whatever but hey if we're getting if
that's the next Marvel series we're
getting what if we need a trailer we've
already had our secret Invasion trailer
where's our whatever and we didn't get
to go to Comic-Con we went to d23 and we
so we didn't get to see any of that
footage
it's true
um here's what I would tell you about
people dying and passing on the mantle
Secret Wars will be the death of Tom
Holland Peter Parker no and the
continuation of Miles Morales because
that's another character about passing
the Naruto right right sure I think by I
think by then Tom Holland my one out
he'll get one more Spider-Man movie
he'll be interested he'll be in his
early mid 50s that's the thing right you
look at the uh
you can only do four backflips now you
have to look at the where do you squeeze
a Spider-Man film in between now and
secret as often as soon as
it was so sad if we don't get that sort
of like street level Spider-Man that
they kind of promised yeah I do and we
need closure for we need closure for MJ
we need closure for Ned and they're kind
of maybe not going to be in this that's
right and so far so far no no Holland
Zendaya uh film announced we are getting
into the spider-verse next year animated
really different universe but we are
getting this a little Miles Morales and
other spider characters but yeah so we
don't know that that's coming soon maybe
and and we have to assume in at least
one of these big Teemo movies your King
Dynasty your secret Wars uh we're
getting Spider-Man yeah he's definitely
going to be in The Avengers movies
there's no way you do it without it but
like yeah I don't I don't know I mean
maybe a fantastic formula can anyone
contact this guy right they all know
Spider-Man's out there doing stuff but
it's like we don't know who he is did
that affect the Marvel Executives as
well everybody but a Sony executive
my question for you guys is Right Secret
Wars feels like the most natural place
to put some of these characters whether
they are variants or whatever Multiverse
yeah yeah yeah yeah if not Secret Wars
it's like easy answer where could where
could specifically
uh Chris Evans Steve Rogers and Robert
Downey Jr Tony Stark fit in okay I have
a pitch we got this year on Disney plus
we got three special presentations sure
we got I am Groot we're off by night
we're about to get Guardians of Galaxy
holiday special well okay uh nothing
announced for 2023 yet they're not
giving up on that what if maybe not next
year but maybe 2024. a Fourth of July
oh
built around Captain America Spangled
man with a plan
wouldn't that be nice and it's and it's
50 minutes Chris Evans doesn't have to
commit to a two and a half hour movie
with tons of CG style and Commandos
maybe Italian Commandos maybe it's
mostly practical like werewolf by night
it's kind of the the indie film
equivalent and it's shot like a 1940s
yeah less CGI you know we can get that
one that great first Captain America
outfit he had that one it's also a
little baggy so Krista
yeah I think I think we should get a I
think I think someone's gonna turn Tony
Stark into an AI at some point yeah it's
a holographic kind of either a
holographic or just like in someone's
suit or whatever I don't know Allah Sam
from Quantum Leap just like oh yeah yeah
I mean that'd be perfect for ironheart
honestly I think it would be really
great yeah maybe that'll come up in our
predictions in a second we're getting
there and then at one point like the
holographic goes to the internet and
shows up uh where pepper pots is like
sleeping in bed and it goes to like pet
her head
yeah Morgan comes around the corner no
I'm your dad now I would love to see
Tony Stark somehow back doors way into
Ultron
whoa whoa there's sites on the internet
you can find that my guy this ain't the
break room okay
um also we want to quickly shout out the
other sponsor helping us bring the break
room to you this week Thanksgiving is
just around the corner uh I don't know
what your plans are I love to cook I
already have two different side dishes
planned and I will be planned hell yeah
dude I start I start uh November 30th in
the previous year thinking about my side
dishes
um but I'm also doing the turkey this
year and you better believe I'm gonna do
a good turkey I'm not settling for some
low class uh bad birdie bro okay
keep that garbage elsewhere I'm getting
my turkey from butcher box that's right
a free range high quality great turkey
you don't have to worry about like is
this a good one is this one that fell
off the trunk you gotta you gotta knock
on your turkey yeah yeah is it Hollow I
don't know I like this uh oh you get
your turkey from butcher box butcher box
it takes all the guesswork out of
picking out High Quality Meats and
Seafood they ship a variety of boxes
right to your door you can kind of pick
what you like they got different kinds
of mixes of different meats you know
depending on what your preference is or
what you eat or don't eat they also
throw in recipe guides and hacks on how
to cook it well because I'll tell you
this I fancy myself a decent cook you
can ruin the best possible ingredient by
not cooking it well and you can Elevate
maybe like a lower level cut by cooking
it really well absolutely butcher box
tells you how to do both of those
um we're here at we're big fans of all
this type of butcher box they have some
really nice bacon their Seafood is great
you get a bacon box you get a whole
bacon and they I they're not running it
right now but they sometimes run a
promotion where you get a year of bacon
when you sign up but it comes all at
once that's right you gotta eat fast and
they they stand there waiting
you don't finish none of this is true no
this is true a butcher box would never
um but uh don't stress about
Thanksgiving turkey butcher boxes
offering our listeners a free turkey
with their first order that's a really
that's a really smart a free turkey it's
like one of those old-timey promotions
you'd hear about uh in the 1950s like
sign up for the bank and get a free tick
yeah you know something that we're doing
at our friendsgiving this year I'm I'm
making this turkey but my roommate's
gonna be smoking some Meats so this is
like this if you if you love your turkey
but sometimes it's on your clothes are
dry or whatever you know uh grab
something else from butcher box you know
and have a couple of things if you got a
big if you've got a big Gathering right
maybe you make a turkey and you make
something else from butcher box make
some steaks yeah cook some bacon
whatever sign up today at butcherbox.com
break room and use codebreak room to get
one 10 to 14 pound turkey free in your
first box that's a lot of turkey that'll
feed a bunch of hungry mouths that's
butcherbox.com break room and use code
break room to claim this deal until they
know we sent you it helps us out helps
you out
it's a win-win uh John you're afraid of
this friendsgiving it wouldn't happen to
be Mark Zuckerberg would it because he
likes to smoke Meats put a little sweet
baby raise on your smoke out here
smoking some Meats
oh my God yeah
hiding behind me man gosh I gotta go
it's time for mandatory fun wow you know
that dog yelled
they can only need one of them at the
break room where we step on dogs
that yelping dog could mean only one
thing we do predictions a lot of
different ways here on the break room
and today we decided to do them a third
way uh Black Panther wakanda forever is
coming out tonight uh I see a super chat
from Jay candrilli who says love
watching the break room every day seeing
wakanda Forever on Saturday and I'm
pumped hey if you're not going to be
able to watch it tonight we are doing
our spoiler-filled episode of the break
room tomorrow so just we wanted to give
you a little spoiler episode so you
could watch it anytime over the weekend
yeah come back come back but right now
we're doing our final predictions right
we've got we combed through the archives
we got every prediction we've ever made
here on the break room about this movie
and we're just going to kind of this is
your last shot this is your last shot to
say yes I agree with my prediction no I
don't agree with that and um we will be
punishing and rewarding accordingly I
love it yes
in a Super Chat eight minutes ago saying
24 minutes so my showing starts oh damn
yeah yeah now there's 16 minutes away
from me oh man uh it's showtime do you
live in a movie theater ramp wouldn't
that be nice
I wonder if that company walked in lived
there
I gotta say the movie that I worked out
was a test apartment complex so yeah wow
this theater is awful small it has a lot
of personal applications
um hey my my first question for you guys
and I'm going to participate to you
because I haven't seen the movie
um
here's the big the big thing right we've
seen the one black panther uh we keep
thinking maybe there's a second suit
somewhere or whatever we thought we
caught a second suit in the trailer but
then the CGI the the suit to look the
same as the other one
um we saw two helmets
helmets we saw two helmets are we gonna
get a second black panther that's not
what who we assume is Sherry but you
know so you're saying two different
characters Don a black panther costume
now let me quick just ask a point of
clarification yes do they what if
somebody puts on the suit has not taken
the heart-shaped herb but they're just
wearing this still counts still counts
still counts there's two different
humans where this you know where it
doesn't count if someone puts on the
suit as a bit okay it doesn't have to be
a human it also could be a pizza oh
they're not human to you they're
different people
all right here we go one two three yes
I think that second helmet that was
there that's like the memorial helmet I
think that's I think this is my
brother's helmet I put on my own so I
don't think anybody else I don't
disagree with that I think that is true
but I still think someone else I think I
think we see shuri ramonda lots of
characters and Baku fighting throughout
the film not till the final act as
somebody put on the Black Panther
costume and that will be Sherry that's
my call seeing some greens in the chat
lots of Green Day throwing the Green
throwing a red if you agree or disagree
moving on okay the big thing that we've
been talking about for months that I'm
backpedaling on SO aggressively uh
spoiler for what I'm gonna say
are we gonna get Dr Doom in wakanda
Forever one two three and also extend
this I'll extend this before you vote
including Insurance credit scene I'm
including post credit scene I'm also
going to include a reference to latviria
or something where the invocation where
we're like that's important Doom you
know multiplication yeah even a map in
the background okay it's just this big
words Library oh yeah the implication
implication wakanda forever one two
three no okay Brandon you're the odd one
I'm so hot on Doom I feel like uh you
know I was bullish on Doom buying a lot
of Doom stock market started to crash a
little bit where it was getting out
there's no Doom but I think that was
counter programming I think it's going
to be Doom uh and Daniel Claire's
character hanging out oh you're buying
the dip yeah
well speaking of which in terms of the
stock crashing on Dr Doom we've been
theorizing that it's possible because of
how they order these posts credit scenes
that they might have withheld post
credit scene from from the Press so that
yeah yeah some new characters didn't get
out okay uh here's my question now is
that do we find the factual they've done
it before however the duck was not in
the Press screening for uh Guardians of
the Galaxy volume one
scene of our lifetime there's a couple
other ones I can't quite remember off
the top of my head here will there be a
second post-credit scenes doesn't
necessarily need to feature Doom uh but
but right now at the end of the credit
but I I want this to be true because
here's here's the thing there's been
some very they're trying they're testing
there's been some very high profile
leaks and spoils right very fair yes
but because like even you know people
like they were getting rockstars or work
at other Publications or YouTube
channels they get to see these movies
early yeah we see you screen crushing
Cosmic Warren you already put your post
credit scene videos out early but they
they get sworn to secrecy right you're
not allowed to they they don't I want
you to spoil and if you do you never get
to come see their movies early again but
maybe they want to even avoid that
possibility right I want this to be true
I want there to be an extra post credit
scene that's a game changer we're
rooting for that I agree I agree uh who
doesn't I want I want 16 post credits I
know Tommy Bechtel came on and was like
don't worry about the post-credit scenes
but he hasn't seen the secret second one
yeah I'm rooting for a post-credit scene
from my pie hole to my flagpole yeah
that's right there we go from your green
to your mean all right the other thing
happy birthday Tommy happy birthday
Tommy happy birthday uh I mean this
movie starts off on a sad note uh
already we know that's coming uh but at
the same time you know do we think
there's going to be another character
death one of the ones we speculated the
most is ramonda she sort of has that
really tragic mind of the trailer she
looks like I lost my whole family yeah
yeah
sure Sherry will snap and blow the world
yeah well that'd be kind of dope
um there has to be some commercial
consequences at the end of this film
someone must die no and shame on you
it's going to be someone who's not going
to be the Black Panther in the future
no okay Queen raimonda Is Alive no the
Black Panther lives okay this is a
Brandon Theory yeah
his theory which I I do like is that
it's not Neymar's fault it's not uh it's
not shuri's fault or uh uh or nakia's
fault or whatever it's gonna be the
fault of atuma or aneka some of these
sort of like secondary the second in
command people that kick off the
conflict like Romeo and Juliet right
it's Benvolio and Mercutio that's right
at all right yeah right
um
he's already got green going one two
three
I think it is going to be an external
thing but I think it's going to be like
United Nations or something like that
they're going to cause it lots of lots
of Reds in the chat for uh for the
romunda theory yeah
I think it's not going to be one of
these guys I think I think Neymar's just
gonna be pissed I think he's gonna be
like with us here at just like what the
events of the first black panther right
he's like you now we're at Jeopardy to
be you know hunting we used to be the
second most hidden Nation now we're the
first you're blowing up our spots you
know I I do see that and that makes a
lot of sense narratively I just think
Marvel is very Adept at like faking us
out with these villains a lot of the
time or their intentions or the reasons
for the things happening and they've
done it a lot the last few movies like
The eternals were the bad guys all along
uh shangshi's dad was in it for his dead
wife Scrolls most famous yeah we all
thought we're gonna be evil they're
actually very nice and kind Mendelson's
great like I think this is another
they're messing with us they're not
showing us a lot they're hiding it
they've shown so little of a tumor and
no more uh and Anika that I'm very
suspicious of their actions and speaking
of Anika did you have something oh no no
go ahead uh this is a Zach Theory yeah
this is exact theory he thinks Anika's
gonna turn on the door milage and here's
my logic okay in in the comics and it's
been hinted at this part of the movie
right there's this uh Sunset of the
dormalage called the midnight Angels
right that are kind of like independent
they're not necessarily always aligned
with wakanda they're still Team Six
they're they get adapt well but not even
SEAL Team Six because they're kind of
like as soon as they have an agenda that
goes against black panther or goes
against the kingdom or general Noriega
yeah yeah they sometimes they fight Wars
on their own and stuff like that and so
I think it deserves to land you in
wakanda jail possibly we've yet to
explore the wakanda and penal system we
don't know uh what the conditions are
like whoa
um but so I think I think that could be
right we we've only seen in the trailer
the kind of fun scene where she's
talking to a koye and it's like I told
you not to bring the knives or whatever
or no that's not a koi it's not a dorm
Elijah she's talking to right uh
okay trying to bring that technology
yeah yeah he's like us you know
since the beginning but I think I think
that character Michaela Cole who plays
that character is a big time actor yeah
uh and so I think there's going to be
some internal conflict in the dorm
Elijah and I think that that Anika
character is going to be part of it
great uh I say no
I say no absolutely not
um I like this idea thank you no no uh
you know why because because you don't
know here's the thing John I'm not I'm
gonna interrupt you before you say
something good I'm gonna say something
better you need a lot of levels of
conflict it can't just be the telekines
telokanites as Kevin finally says right
you need internal
conflicted
you need internal conflict and we think
you know in the first movie embaku
internal conflict obviously Daniel
kaluya's character internal conflict
right like so far we don't know of any
internal conflict in this film so I
think that's going to come from unique
here's why I see no I feel like we've
seen the Kia in some kind of midnight
angels-esque yeah
people were like yeah that sounds dope
but she could still be a Midnight Angel
and then we have some midnight Angels
going against the midnight that's right
I think the door milage is gonna be like
let's just have factions now
it works for aw it could work for uh
dark order
um here's one of mine here's my mind uh
the reason the conflict starts is
because Neymar actually wants some
vibranium he's like he's like you guys
have kind of screwed us over I'm not
interested in this so you know what
we're gonna do what everyone else wants
and we're just gonna take your vibranium
[ __ ] the French who are the people who
you know in the trailer okay we've got a
huge fan base in France yeah
that's what they're there for boom
and sometimes in like Antarctica
somebody write this stuff down so that
we can hold down accountable it's on
video also real quick we're about to run
out of time but we are very close to the
Super Chat threshold if we hit I think
we need about 20 more bucks and we'll do
we'll do bonus time I said 250 but we
said yeah so you know we have competing
oh we'll do it at 200. otherwise we're
cutting out hard
a movie yeah all right a couple last uh
last ones and then we're gonna do a
rapid fire
um
there's no heart-shaped Herb At All
Monger at all burned it and there's no
more it was effective
do we think there was some hidden herb
hell yeah or maybe Sherry maybe sure he
is gonna create some kind of synthetic
or hidden herb is what we call John's
blood compartment
will there be some kind of heart-shaped
herb thing in this movie these three two
one absolutely yeah
the only chance there's not is if shuri
is the new one in the suit and she has
somehow jacked up the suit so much but
it gives her power so we want we want a
black panther that can jump yeah 30 feet
in the air and can do crazy stuff they
need to be super powerful it's part of
the mythology it's part of being the
Avatar boss it's important boss put that
there for a reason don't take it away
great yep uh okay uh one question about
Riri Williams will Riri Williams have
any connection to that Oakland outreach
program we know she's from Chicago we
know she's at MIT we theorized for a
long time that maybe they'll change her
backstory a little bit to this Oakland
outreach program it doesn't seem like
they're doing that but I still really
like that yeah
yeah well what if what if they opened up
the Oakland Outreach at the end of uh
Black Panther one what if in the interim
they've also set him up in Chicago in
Miami and New York in Houston and
whatever right okay three two one I'm
doing this but it's with this like I
think they're gonna surprise me but I
don't think they're going to change that
but here's why I think it is going to
happen uh they could just be giving
scholarships to like bright young women
right and it doesn't necessarily have to
be people from Oakland it could just be
like yeah hey we we love what you're
doing over there in Chicago we want to
send you an MIT yeah yeah uh okay last
question and then we get to Rapid Fire
well John need to pee at any time during
that okay well this is loaded you can
you you can guarantee Victory here but
also well the majority of people
watching need to pay attention
um uh uh waterfalls in the chat if you
are thinking
do a pre-p I tried but my prostate's the
size of it also I'm making the choice
now I've been
um preloading Coke Zero all day long
I will not be purchasing a beverage in
this movie for this exact reason it's
the beverage if you get those like gels
that uh marathon runners eat like jelly
beans
one of those what are those little beads
that you put in water that expand over
time put those in your stomach
uh we're so [ __ ] We're not gonna get
to the movie theater on time okay now
now we can take our time a little bit
but this is the speed round this is the
cameos speed round here we go we know
that Neymar uh is mutant uh we've gotten
a couple mutants but here's my question
any X-Men gonna be in this movie any
X-Men gonna be in this movie three two
one okay no we don't like that uh this
one's a sad one are we gonna get a
t'challa any footage at all because you
know we know we get a mural like it's
not gonna happen we have a mural I'm not
gonna count anything in like the opening
credits the Marvel Studios logo yeah
that would count I don't think so three
two one I don't think they're gonna do I
think I think we'll get something I like
being on his voice yeah I like his voice
and it will be really heartbreaking get
this banana all right here's the
alternative to that uh another character
who's dead in the MCU killmonger can we
see uh can we see killmarger coming into
this movie maybe uh standing in the
ancestral plane or something like that
three two one I'm saying yeah oh John
going yes oh you think it might be in
the ancestral place okay we were talking
the office that like the establishing
you go to the ancestral plane you see
dead black panthers if like raimondo
does get a hold of a heartbreaker she's
just like using heart-shaped herb to
receive her son like in the essential
plane like that's that's some heavy
stuff that's very heavy um we're getting
a t'challa funeral right so you'd think
that people who are close to that
character might be there do you think
we're gonna get uh a Bucky Barnes who
spent a lot of time in wakanda in a
rehabbing he's mad about his arm this
feels like this feels like the second
funeral like they did the public funeral
and this is like for the home team yeah
yeah so I will do I'll do like this a
little blank I think I think some of the
most sense he makes the most sense
he's guaranteed to be there that's the
secret book is just add catering for
every MCU movies like now you need me in
there now uh well and then speaking of
speaking of other people I'm gonna say
any sort of Avenger that we don't
already expect to be in this movie you
know again it's a funeral first Sam
Wilson can show up right absolutely uh
Don Cheadle a good show at the beginning
if we consider those Avengers yeah yes
the the sort of people who are in
Avengers movies
yeah yeah I think that could be a little
surprise Cameo there I think they're
getting like a lot of characters in the
movie I mean it's basically taking the
field uh if you've ever bet on golf or
whatever so like I like that that some
other Avenger will show up in this movie
I like that great and then last but not
least you got to get a little Ulysses
claw oh no he's dead I know he's dead
but like one way you know we've been
watching
the spoilers for the most recent episode
of Andover but it is a doozy if you're
not watching Andor and you don't have
wakanda forever tickets tonight you have
no excuse me
good tonight
two more episodes here we go Claw is
claw gonna be in this movie I was just I
was just begging for no there's no
chance no chance no chance get out of
here you're hurting your average yeah
a lot of green in the chat and I can't
quite tell it's a speed round what the
green but I love it I think that was for
The Avengers yeah now we got no no claws
yeah so at new rockstars in the chat
which will make it easier for our our
researcher Anna at home to pull some of
these questions and for us to see um so
throw those in we got 15 extra minutes
wow look look look how many times not
only is John guaranteed to go to the
bathroom how many times
three plus can I tell you I think Zach
when we saw Thor 11 Thunder together I
might have snuck out twice you might
have done two I might have done a two
first well here's here's the trick I
gotta just real quick brief aside the
trick is go during the previews yeah
wait until maybe what you think is the
last preview oh we did we did talk about
preview predictions oh oh we were gonna
do some preview predictions we'll we'll
do that during the stoppage time here
but go during the previews because that
way if you go before the preview start
and there's 20 minutes of previews 20
minutes of stoppage time when you're on
your blade and you're just sitting there
juicing it up you know I'm juicing well
that's also I mean that's mistake number
one you're hiding the herb go one size
lower on your drink yeah than you
normally go I don't know I'm just trying
to train my bladder to be as big as a
large drink
you know what I mean that's that's how
it goes okay uh let's do some trailer
predictions real fast uh but we did we
have been getting uh super chats or
psycho Sidekicks I just saw it it's
great that's all I'll say yeah okay so
psycho sidekick that was responsible of
you and we appreciate that endorsement
um I think whale water that'll make you
pee yes right Avatar with water for sure
because it's absolutely gonna happen
it's a fox movie owned by Disney you
know they're getting that in there it's
also the next big movie it's like the
only other big movie this year whale the
whale absolutely the whale no it's an
a24 giant guardians of galaxy holiday
series
it would have to be attached I don't
think feeders want to put uh it would
have to be attached to the movie somehow
on that note how about Glass Onion which
is getting a theatrical release sure I
say yeah I think I think the movie
theaters want you to come see it in the
theater and I'm gonna go and also for
that if you don't know like Glass Onion
the knives out sequel It's coming out in
theaters a month before it comes out on
Netflix and one of this day and date
stuff so actually a decent number of
people might go see this in theaters
because they don't await the month me
I'm going with friends um uh okay
yes that was mine guaranteed right
that's a lot no shot that's a lot okay
we just got a trailer today for John
Wick four do we think they got it in
time do we think they got it in on time
nah that's is that Sony time moving I
think so I think so I don't know I don't
know they might have they might have
dropped it today because they're not
dropping on the movie what about now
this is a stretch Marvel's only been
giving us one trailer for the next movie
basically we don't get the next trailer
until that movie's almost out the next
Marvel movie after quantumania is the
Marvels do we get of the Marvels no no
as much
great great uh but no I don't think so
okay well let's flip the other side of
the coin right uh the next DC movie
coming out is Shazam Fury
we've seen a trailer for that but uh
that would make sense but I think so
yeah yeah maybe okay oh how about final
one final one Indiana Jones five oh yeah
give me a Super Bowl trailer good call
good call okay let's go somewhere
through some of our super chats Jay
Cantrell saying love watching the break
room every day seeing wakanda Forever on
Saturday and I am popped Jay Cantrell
we're pumped down you're bad I'm sad
that whatever is happening in your life
means you can't see it until Saturday
get your friends to you know see this
[ __ ] on a weekday uh let's see Zach
Braddock that's interesting uh sort of a
combination of strong names not quite uh
cap returning infinity stone short I
don't know what that means like if we
were to see cap again it's him returning
those Affinity Stones
because he would meet some very
interesting people that's a good pitch
pury sent in a Super Chat saying uh idea
to get scarjo back in secret Wars have
Nat and Elena be variants where in their
University Elena was the Avenger that
died and that is the Helena role and
then bring that Nat back to the MCU also
what if just a little Studio politics
they do this as a make good for old scar
joke because well he has a film
they owe her some bucks so that'd be a
nice way to make good news so pissed
about that he almost left yes yeah he
was sided with scarjo on that reev
Wilson saying props to the mods today
hey good job good job to the mods every
day but thank you today I assume that
means they were doing a good job uh
moderating the spoilers we don't talk
about the mods enough but they they
really are great girl Mr JD all the
others in there Chrissy Anna uh
everybody that's doing great work
Christian unpronounceable reminding
everyone to like the video please please
do like the video uh Bucky Barnes ATL
happy Veterans Day tomorrow to you to my
fellow vets and yes happy Veterans Day
to all veterans yes there uh thank you
for your service yeah yeah thank you for
your service and we hope you get the day
off we don't Bucky Barnes says I see you
Costa and hope my hurricane folk are
good Bucky Barnes come fight me you
coward what what he's saying let's see
he's saying good things he sees you I
want to hear it
to our maritoba offices I'll fight
uh you know
uh Aaron storm about to head into the
theater to see what kind of forever 7
P.M Eastern was basically you're in
there right now you better be peeing
right now over here right now Hamilton
Ontario Canada hey so close shout out to
our Canadian Brethren maritoba I think
uh Christian unpronounceables also in
Canada GSU Eagle also pointing out we
need closure on the blob of Venom left
over from no way home Kevin feige was
probably so pissed about when he saw
that well see that Kevin feige needed a
final cut on that movie I think he did
and I don't think it was in the Final
Cut
is like doing stuff just to screw with
James Gunn in his films like you think
Sony's not doing stuff just to screw
with Marvel well there would lose so
much money
yeah but just it's not it's not gonna
ruin the relationship but it's just a
little just a little tweak I don't know
you're right though we do need the
Symbiotes yeah symbiotes
GSU Eagle also shouting out donating to
John's hidden herb hell yeah hell yeah
dog an ambassador in the chat pointing
out that lin-manuel Miranda is in Percy
Jackson I heard about that yeah is that
true is that it is it is true oh I don't
remember I saw a very funny tweet about
that and I can't remember we're getting
a new season of Golden Compass speaking
of lin-man one yeah see Bucky Barnes ATL
says haha I love John we're brothers
that fight that's right oh okay is that
kind of good it's like Jessica and Tommy
yeah we are getting a second season of
Golden Compass despite everyone's best
efforts
hey man they got some badass CGI animals
in this show that's all I can say
because I've never watched it but um
we're doing it from Toronto hello
Toronto Oh Canada is coming in strong
today
you know
simu come on the show please
um uh I want to shout out the poll we
ran when are you seeing wakanda forever
this is so surprised uh 28 saying this
weekend 25 saying tonight a good quarter
of the audience that's pretty good 23
saying tomorrow Friday I guess is
assumed to not be part of the weekend
and sometime after that 20 this was very
similar to a poll that was on Twitter
today that we ran where it was pretty
much split equally four ways which is
very interesting I'll say this I think
out of most Marvel movies that first
black panther film had like the longest
tale other than maybe Avengers end game
which got a re-release and people are
talking about because of the we're still
kind of feeling the effects of the
pandemic in production there are like no
movies this year yeah right like
literally until Avatar wear the water it
comes out in mid December yeah around
Christmas it's gonna be a juggernaut
yeah that's like a lot of people are
going to wait to watch but and also
glass then you'll be a very different
demographic that'll appeal to an older
demographic super movies usually a
little younger but like you know back in
the day like black panther would come
out and then there'd be like a mission
impossible movie the next weekend and
then there'd be like a big thing the
weekend after that it's gonna have
multiple weeks there's a reason Black
Adam has been number one at the box
office three weeks in a row because
nothing else has come out right it's
probably a big weekend well conover's
gonna make a ton of money it'll be the
number one movie for a while um so it
says leave fart before I watch wakanda
forever I don't know what that means
farts oh Leaf I think it's a Canadian
Leaf dashing out of the way okay I don't
know great uh Dylan sent in a question
asking do we get a hint of secret
Invasion either I'm gonna take this as
either a trailer which they have never
done a show trailer at a movie again
they could try it out I don't know if
they will but like will there be
anything in wakanda Forever that hints
and Scrolls or a secret invasion of some
kind is that the secret post credit
they're hiding they dropped it scroll
into one division yeah right it's an
early age and there was a scrolling Loki
didn't have any lines or was it right
right there in the background yeah
I really really really feel like this
movie is gonna be pretty insular and
siled it's again it's the end of phase
four and if I guess pointed out a
million times or even said the it's the
epilogue or the coda to phase four right
like uh yeah that was a joke from James
Gunn about the holiday special yeah just
he called it oh because it comes out
afterwards because it wasn't on it
someone was like oh it's not on Facebook
yeah yeah thank you thank you uh anyways
Christian pronounceable says shout out
everyone in the chat have a good weekend
I won't be here tomorrow what what do
you have to do well I do see a lot of
people saying that they're gonna avoid
they can see the movie there may not
show up tomorrow they'll watch it for
spoilers tomorrow's episode will be
spoiler filled it will be full of people
but it'll be Evergreen in the sense that
you can watch it Saturday Sunday Monday
when everything whenever you do watch it
hit that like hit that hit like like
button
oh yes uh anything else you guys want to
discuss anything funny you've been
watching like you like this segment what
are you doing watching lately I mean
obviously we've all been watching Andor
and and you should too yeah we oh gosh
we want to do an indoor break room so
badly but uh we don't know if you'll
click on it but our worst performing
break room of all time I think I think
in December
which no one cares about it anymore in
this season one predicting season two
could be fun again they're making a
second season but I mean the thing that
we're all talking about in the office is
the dongs on the White Lotus oh man the
one put your HBO put your HBO Max
subscription to use the White Lotus you
can watch it you can watch baz luerman's
Elvis and then you can watch yeah well
what else just something else just
dropped out don't worry darling don't
worry darling for free garbage I have
been watching speaking of dongs uh no uh
I have been watching I started the
patient on uh Hulu which has Donald
Gleason and Steve Carell okay it's a
very interesting very good drama I'm not
finished with it yet but the most
interesting thing being is exactly it's
a drama that's a half hour which is
fascinating interesting it's very
surprising and you're it's always
jarring every time when the episode ends
it ends at such a great moment every
time you want to keep watching it check
out the patience starring General hux
and Michael Skye on Hulu uh there's also
a crazy episode of Atlanta that came out
a couple of weeks ago if you know I need
to catch up look up all the episodes
especially a crazy I'm a couple episodes
behind on that land I need to catch up
that's it thank you for reminding me I
need to watch this yeah yeah let's get
through some of the rest of these super
chats before we have to say goodbye TD
Jones says just came from watching
wakanda forever I gave it
uh Jeremy Leah saying I just bought my
ticket for Monday evening at the old Sea
Cafe I don't know that I don't know what
that is so you can sing it till Monday
that's gonna be a long so I can cry
hysterically some people gotta work over
there yeah
people are traveling I'm gonna say some
say something whoa I have to
have to that's right I'm gonna cry a lot
yeah and then I gotta go to work with
Zach tomorrow hey I never judge people
we literally got to go
um it is down the street uh from us here
in Manitoba Canada I gotta step in my
dog and get him some food
well you feed the dog you step on him it
comes out you put it back again hey uh
never buy dog food again finally uh
thank you all for joining us and thank
you for the folks that have been here
all week or yeah thank you for the folks
that have been consuming all of our what
kind of forever content since we got
that Comic-Con trailer we've been going
pretty hard on this film because we're
so excited about it there's so much to
talk about that's not gonna end once we
see the movie for sure uh our ending
explained video will be coming out on
the channel tomorrow and T is hosting
that Eric Voss is doing the breakdown
now if you've been watching any of his
Marvel breakdowns recently
they've been pushing an hour long okay
sure
we've been working on this video for
like three weeks and and this is a
direct quote Eric Voss thinks this is
the best breakdown he's ever he did say
that that was really sweet uh and so you
know that'll be coming out Saturday
we're hoping Saturday midday morning
something like that on the channel as
soon as we can get it finished but
whenever you watch this movie this
weekend uh next week whenever check the
Channel watch that breakdown like that
video uh we're we're almost as excited
for Eric's breakdown as we are for the
film mt's post credit scene or or
post-credits scenes yes and ending
explains coming out of the channel
tomorrow yes and then we're gonna have
some some really strong content next
week from Eric and Mt and Whitney and
Jessica and our host obviously on the
break room here we're going to be
talking about the ramifications of the
movie Jessica will finally get to talk
about this movie yeah we've uh forced
her not to speak about it if you're one
of those people who has to wait until
Tuesday or whatever to see this movie
with your friends Jessica has a
spoiler-free review out on the channel
and she just gets into sort of like you
know team and what's so great about this
movie and some of the soundtrack stuff
there's no spoilers for the plot or
anything like that no cameos or anything
like that check that out it's a really
great video and I I watched it and I
feel like I'm ready to go into this
movie with like a little bit more
background and I don't feel like I've
you know know too much about it that's
right yeah so in summation thank you all
for watching and staying with us here
till the end uh Happy Veterans Day uh
tomorrow uh John was wrong about almost
all his predictions and keeping Gucci to
moochi
[Music]
thank you